in South Florida you've got a 13 Mile
Stretch between the Everglades to the
west and the Atlantic Ocean to the east
so you've got limited land and you've
got millions right of people wanting to
live down here Miami Beach average sale
price is there up 72 got prices up
double digits in Boca Wellington Bell
Harbor Del Rey all across Southern
Florida Miami is a new city and you go
back to 1920 and there was this guy
named Carl Fisher he was selling
Waterfront Lots in Miami Beach an acre
on the water in Miami Beach for guess
how much money 50 bucks 500 500 Fast
Forward the Austin Martin residences
side in downtown Miami that's on the
water is like 100 million dollar acre a
lot of people make fun of Brokers
they're just like sleazy car salesmen
and for me I'm like that's the
playground where I want to compete when
you think about a young person who wants
to get into real estate what's your best
advice for them all right guys bang bang
about Omar here with me uh you've sold
three billion dollars real estate in
South Florida and a lot of people think
it's over like prices are down 10 20
percent uh the FED is acting all crazy
are people still moving to Miami it's
like well [ __ ] let's just talk about it
yeah um I think a great place to start
is like why South Florida right I don't
think that's a place that many people
historically were like if you're a young
person who wants to have a great career
in real estate like oh move to Miami
yeah talk a little bit about like why
South Florida's always been so
interesting to you and like why did you
stay here rather than go to a New York
or a California or something like that
yeah absolutely so first of all thank
you for having me this is uh wild pretty
crazy to be here and obviously know some
of the people you've interviewed and
being here with them is just like wow
okay I'm not at that level but I'm
getting there and uh why South Florida
so
for me personally it was just family my
family's here and I'm from Honduras so
it was close by so it just made sense
and a lot of success is luck based I
feel like you'd be fooling yourself not
real too yeah oh yeah you've you're one
of that you're like it's not long it's
like you worked for it right no no it's
probability you CR okay uh probability
we can go a length about this I'm big on
luck I'm big on luck and gratitude it's
like fake no dude this will be a now
this will be a podcast about luck and
your gratitude um there's a
psychological concept if you and I walk
out of here and let me buy a car right
you're unlucky bruh no no you may be
like oh that's unlucky because I got hit
by the car yeah I might be like yo I was
lucky because I survived yeah it's all
psychological it's probability
probability of like hey you were walking
there you got hit by the car or whatever
this mathematical content probability
okay so the probability okay so here
okay I'll go back for it I'll take the
word luck out of it not that I agree not
that I agree not that I agree but just
to appease you and to talk about
realization and to talk about South
Florida probability versus luck is is
bifurcated yeah so for me my parents had
the problem probabilistically we're like
let's get out of won't do that and let's
get into Miami I came to Miami and I was
like this place has everything I think I
need right including family which is the
most sort of pressing part so basically
when I was graduating I had offers to go
do investment banking in New York and
Chicago and things like that the reason
I stayed again was for family but what I
ended up realizing very quickly was
Malcolm Gladwell talks about this and
David and Goliath about being a big fish
in a small pond so pretty much when I I
got an internship at a hedge fund which
is a huge breakthrough for me friends of
friends connected me and um at the hedge
fund it sort of opened my eyes and gave
me sort of like the in to be able to get
into real estate and financial
investments at a high level right but
what I noticed was that this hedge fund
could not find
hard-working Talent young in Miami
because to your point which what you
just asked is like why Miami right like
why not New York Chicago and all these
things so for me that became a huge like
Boon to my career because very quickly
once I got into real estate private
equity and now brokering
um my name sort of started coming around
a lot because I instantly started
dealing having doing deals with these
big players
um and I was the sort of only one of
very few young guys working their asses
off day in and day out
um so that for me was like kind of what
got me to where we I am today which
we'll talk about but I think the reason
why people like South Florida
and the reason why it'll continue
growing is because For the First Time
Ever you're seeing this demographic
shift which I think is so interesting
it's Florida historically has been a
retirement community that's why people
come here right now you've got
downsizing Baby Boomers whose kids are
out of the house all over New York the
Northeast I mean across the country and
they Florida has historically been the
place where they go right what's
interesting now is now their sons that
are 19 22 27 listening to you or
um what's the pen floor the pen gaming
guy
um day four night Dave fortnite Dave
Portnoy like they're in they're in Miami
they're in South Florida they're here so
for the first time ever you've got the
two largest demographic populations both
having a reason to come down here right
so that's huge and for me I see it where
hey the kid wants to come to Miami to
work in Miami and live in this sort of
paradise and their parents are moving
down here too so now the whole family is
getting back together in Miami here Fort
Lauderdale or Palm Beach so for me
that's extremely unique real estate has
always been and I'm sure you've had guys
and people probably listening to this
real estate is a tried and true asset
it's very similar to Bitcoin in terms of
like heart you can't make more of it
things like that
um good inflation hedge so they're not
you're not making more real estate and
in South Florida you've got a 13 Mile
Stretch between the Everglades to the
west and the Atlantic Ocean to the east
so you've got limited land and you've
got millions right of people wanting to
live down here yeah it's getting
expensive and it'll keep it'll continue
to get expensive but when you're talking
about that you can get a two-bedroom
apartment in the middle of the city in
Brickell for 500 Grand 600 Grand that in
New York has to be one two one five
million dollars and like easy like not
like an impressive one just to live
there right so like we're still half
priced and a lot of these employers are
coming down here so that for like many
other reasons I could dive into like the
demographics I think is super are
interesting the weather tax-friendly
climate the demographics so no
demographics is that both the downsizing
the older Baby Boomers and the younger
guys both want to be here it's not just
one or the other now right it's like hey
my MD my managing director at my shop is
moving to Palm Beach I want to go and
live in Fort Lauderdale yeah and take
the bright line up and down work so now
you've got both of them coming down
right so for me to have friends I go to
Harvard Warden MIT Stanford and for them
telling me that Miami is a target
destination blows my mind and that's
only starting right because what I think
is most interesting about population
migration that a lot of people I think
underestimate is that whenever you see a
trend in anything in crypto and
Investments or whatever the trend may be
you think okay are you going to get
reversion to the mean
or are you gonna get perpetuating sort
of like Network effects right is it
going to continue and I think population
migration has perpetuating
self-reinforcing Network effects where
the more people move down here the more
people want to move down here the more
they wake up and the blistering coal of
the blistering heat whether it be out in
the midwest or in Baltimore Maryland
freezing their asses off one winter day
they open up their phone and they've got
you in Miami they portanoia Miami some
actress or model or book writer or
whatever it is Ken Griffin in Miami
they're like holy [ __ ] everybody's going
there and then their parents are like
Hey we're looking to buy a house in Fort
Lauderdale
right so for that to just continue
trickling in I really think Miami's in
the first inning and it's it's we're
scratching the surface of what the city
is going to become so a lot of people
when they think of uh real estate they
think of single-family homes uh or
apartments you deal with multi-families
for the most part talk a little bit as
to like why is multi-family in South
Florida so interesting and like why are
you so focused on that part of the
market absolutely so again here I'll use
the word luck I fell into multi-family
by luck but probabilistically a lot of
people were buying multi-family so when
I broke into real estate I
by the probability was that there was
more people buying multi than like Hotel
office retail things like that so I fell
into a shop that did multi-family as I
was learning and cutting my teeth with
it I'm like holy [ __ ] this is a really
good investment so the reason why it's
so good it's because
covid came right and hotels completely
stopped right office work from home
completely stopped retail e-commerce
completely not completely stopped but
took a big hit so all these asset
classes within the real estate umbrella
have really seen some hard times and
residential has to but it always comes
back because as long as you get good
real estate at a good location
somebody's going to pay to have a roof
over their head that's never going to
change you need somewhere to sleep right
hotel is different economy hits a
recession people travel less right same
thing with office retail and other asset
classes so the three big asset classes
which have weathered a lot of the storms
and and had have been like a hedge for
inflation real estate naturally is is
multi-family
industrial and self storage for
different reasons
multi-family for me was one where like
I understood why I wanted to live in
Brickell versus Coral Gables and why
somebody would rather be in Delray Beach
over Pompano Beach or Fort Lauderdale or
you know yeah other locations in South
Florida so for me it's like okay I kind
of I can sell this and I can pitch this
and I believe it because I'm living and
breathing it and for you for example
with like crypto which you're really
known for it's like you live and breathe
crypto like you understand the coins and
the tokenomics and like what these
people are thinking so you're like paw
committed so you're confidence in the
investment like just like flows through
you so for me that was multi-family and
to answer your question about
residential which is like single-family
homes mom and pop stuff to multi to
multi-family which is like an apartment
building like the people that follow
Grant Cardone look like he buys
apartment buildings and stuff it's
if you buy a house you've got your
biggest expenses outside of real estate
and real estate taxes and insurance your
biggest expenses are
um capex Capital expenditures right so
like a roof an air conditioning unit
things like that so in a house you've
got one roof one tenant
right that roof goes bad like that's
going to be a bad year for you because
that tenant's paying you 2 000 a month
but the roof goes bad the old 30 grand
50 Grand whatever it could be
so in a multi-family building you've got
a building with
80 units 80 different tenants paying you
monthly or 150 tenants you know we've
sold 600 tenant buildings like 600 unit
buildings that only have six Roots have
eight roofs have two roofs so basically
this big ticket item
is sort of cushioned by the amount of
people paying you and then if your
tenant leaves in a single family home
you're going to see no income for the
next month or two months or three months
depending how hot that market is at any
given time
within multi-family you've got 800 to
call it 100 people in your building one
leaves another one comes in two leave
and alone comes in you literally need
like 20 people to say hey I no longer
want to live in this building at any
price point that you can put in front of
me
for you to start like thinking okay I've
got a loan I gotta pay down right so
it's such a safe investment it's so
resilient and it's got all the benefits
that real estate generally has that it's
like the hottest asset class within real
estate so I fell into it by Locker bro
at probability and it's just been a wild
ride I'm sure you could I mean I even
want to ask you I'm like you I'm sure
you you stumbled upon Bitcoin years ago
probably earlier than most and the more
you read on it
you're like holy [ __ ] this is really
cool oh my God this is really cool and
then as you're like guys guy and you're
like telling people and kind of waking
people up and shaking them to it you're
you're more and more pot committed as
you're doing it right of course so for
me it's been called seven years now that
I've just been
helping people invest in multi-family in
South Florida um
and now yeah it's been three billion
dollars of sales mind you with a team so
for me it's me and five teams two of two
of which me and five team members
two of which are like support analyst
type roles and then three which are like
client facing and closing deals and
trying to like negotiate contracts and
stuff got it uh you guys are Brokers
Brokers correct when most people think
of investing in real estate they think
of like some rich billionaire who like
wants to go and put their money into the
real estate and the the principal gets
all the glory yeah what's unique about
you all is that you're Brokers you're
actually helping people buy and sell
um and you don't want to be the
Principal in a lot of cases based on
conversation we've had in the past
explain like why do you like being the
broker
yeah it's it's a unique perspective I
think
um I want to see where I start so yeah
because there's a lot that goes into it
and and I think I need to start high
level so about people listening because
it's nuanced differences right I think
the general takeaway for me was it's
actually a Warren Buffett quote that
says uh profits come and go but fees
never falter
right if I'm selling a building for a
hundred million dollars call it let's
say I'm making one million dollars in
commission right if that building falls
to 80 million dollar value I'm making
800 Grand right so Skyrocket so 120
million dollars I'm making 1.2 million
dollars
and you know with a team of five people
it ends up being a very lucrative sort
of investment when you're splitting
those those fees
um I'm in there I'm at a shop called
brucadia which is like The Brokerage
house and they get some of that fee but
what ends up happening is it's like a
time irrelevant
investment if that makes sense where you
could be the smartest guy in the world
smartest [ __ ] person if you bought
real estate in 2006 and raise a bunch of
money
because you wanted to have a three-year
flip into 2011 2010 like you lost a
bunch of money and in the investment
World especially when you're dealing
with bigger properties if you lose money
once and you probably speak to you like
your your spigots dried up like you're
like you're done you know so for me
brokeraging has this financial term it's
called sharp ratio which is basically
like
the volatility the volatility
relative to the marginal return unlike
how successful you're going to be
typically it's an investment so it's
like yeah this investment might make me
a little bit more money but I could go
broke or I could go Bust or make a
little bit more money so that's a bad
investment right
the reason why people want to be
principals in bgps is because
it allows people to look at a
billionaire like George Perez or Stephen
Ross or maybe more local people like
David Martin and stuff like that and be
like wow I want to be that dude right
and I'm like dude for every guy that's
like that
there is a hundred thousand people
trying to be that dude
a
B I've talked to those guys I've sold
deals to them and for them I've sold
deals that they've built and I've sold
it for them
these guys it's it's realistically like
looking out of Tom Brady or Cristiano
Ronaldo
or LeBron James and being like I want to
be that dude the reason I say that is
because these guys on a Saturday night
midnight Sunday morning 7 A.M they are
like calling and they're they're what I
don't know if this is like a bad term
but like I don't think they'd mind it if
I would tell them they're like deal
junkies they [ __ ] love real estate
and like finding the deal cutting the
deal and making it happen so for me it's
like I see that and I'm like okay like
that's my competition if I want to be
them right brokers
which I think a lot of the people
listening to this could probably relate
a lot of people make fun of Brokers
those guys don't know what they're
talking about they're always selling me
numbers that don't really match up and
and they're just like sleazy car
salesmen and for me I'm like that's the
playground where I want to compete I
want to compete against the guy this guy
like a poor reputation and can't add two
and two right so by playing in that
space
and now for me especially in South
Florida multi-family when we're selling
100 million dollar buildings there's
five shops that do that nobody goes to a
random mom-and-pop broker
and says hey I want I want George Perez
is going to go to a random Joe Schmo and
says I want you to sell this building
for 100 million dollars he's going to go
to a shop that's got the clientele and
the network that can sell 100 million
dollar buildings and those shops there's
five of them here for Katie is one of
them so for me it's like all right I'm
competing against five dudes
last year especially when the market was
red hot
we sold a 308 unit building in Sunny
Isles
price ended up getting close to call it
130 million dollars give or take we had
24 offers in writing of different groups
across the country really there were
International folks New York folks
everywhere that basically said I can pay
close to 130 million for this building
24 groups that are backed have the track
record out of those 24 groups that
actually gave us written Lois for this
asset
there was 500 phone calls that we had
and there was an extra of 50 people that
were like I can pay 110 million I can
pay 115 million but I can't get to 120
125 130. so for me when I'm selling one
of these hot assets that you want to own
in a prime location in a primary Market
I see the competition it's a thousand
[ __ ] people with a lot of money that
are very smart and well backed
then I look at the brokeraging side and
it's like people that are just trying to
like make a quick Buck or very
short-term focused and have largely a
bad reputation as an industry so being
that like one bright light you know
amongst many gives I think me the
leverage long term to kind of be where I
want to be and then that relative to hey
I'm also not taking any risk right I'm
not taking any risks so
I could have a great year and may call
it two million dollars I could have a
bad year and only make 100 Grand 300
Grand that's that's the bad part about
broker Gene
so for me that's from a career
perspective why why it makes sense
there's other things to touch on but I
want to pause how much uh like how much
do Brokers get paid fee wise like does
it vary yeah it does vary a lot so
that's another good question actually so
when you sell a million dollar deal you
can charge you know call it a three
percent fee and hey residential deal
people would charge three percent and
both uh real estate agents get paid
three percent so it's like six percent
total correct okay yeah exactly so for
me it's like hey million dollar deal
sixty thousand dollars is gonna go to
Brokers right when you go to a 100
million dollar deal you don't go and
it's not a six million dollar fee like
many things in life it's like the bigger
you get it doesn't really get more
complicated sometimes it even gets
easier because when I'm selling a deal
from Blackstone to related or whatever
it is it's like they've got their stuff
buttoned down like everything's single
file online when you go and sell a two
million dollar deal from a mom and pop
that's owned it for 20 years it's like
oh the guy on the left my tenant over
there yeah he pays me cash on a napkin
every other month and I'm like why how
do I how do I pitch this so yeah I gotta
buy it so fee wise it varies I want to
say generally speaking
you know between uh five million dollar
deal or a 100 million dollar deal you're
making anywhere from like 400 Grand on
like the low end to like a million
dollars on the high end like a million
dollar fee is like special it's Unique
and you really knocked it out of the
park for your client and like
a nuanced deal right a cookie cutter
deal that's like hey it's a beautiful
building people are going to love it
you're gonna sell it like the client
knows that he's giving you a easy sell
for the most part and they're
negotiating and and they'll negotiate
like hey do you want to sell a big sexy
building in Brickell like I know you do
right so like instead of and we're not
gonna go and charge them a million
dollars it'll be you know call it half a
million or whatever it is and then
there's a lot of things that go into it
like client relationship this is the
first time you're going to work with
this guy if it is you want to be a
little more lenient on pricing to kind
of win over the business longer term
things like that but typically you're
making you can ballpark at 500 to a
million dollars per closing
um yeah you mentioned earlier some
people uh Ken Griffin Stephen Ross uh
George Perez what makes these people
special like what why are they so good
you mentioned earlier like being a deal
junkie but what else
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more rested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
in each sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eatsleep.com pump not only do
I sleep on it every night it literally
changed my life and I begged the
founders to let me invest in the company
eight sleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep
so the overarching actual like the
Nuance that I've noticed in all of them
is they are hyper hyper responsive
crazy
if you have a deal that they're looking
for
you send them a text you send them an
email and they are responding within
seven minutes it could be Friday night
it could be Sunday morning so I think it
just goes back to like okay if they're
that incessant about like just
responding and getting in front of you I
can't imagine behind the scenes how much
more they're studying and talking and
doing all these things so
doing a deal with them is different from
like knowing them personally but it's
it's it's that it's I I can they're like
foaming at the mouth for Real Estate
right and I think if you think of
someone like Michael Jordan right it's
like whether he had a fever whether he
was sick whether he was whatever he was
going to practice he was giving his a
thousand percent every time at practice
his teammates gave him a hard time
because it was such a hard ass at
practice but he's just like he's foaming
at the mouth for this like opportunity
day in and day out and I think
our economy is sort of like self-selects
where it's like you have to be that way
to be the one percent not financially
but be the one percent in an industry if
you want to be a one percent in soccer
in crypto and Twitter in media you just
have to live and breathe your product
and it's exactly what they do it's for
me it's inspiring honestly it's you know
I graduated with that sentiment like I
want to be these people and like
realistically I see their life and I'm
like wow I mean I like multi-family I
like South Florida
but I also like hanging out with my
friends right so and I don't think
that's a wrong thing but it's just like
having that perspective I think is is
good
and and that's kind of what what makes
them them right and it's sometimes I
mean like a 32 year old much younger
that doesn't have their Prestige and all
those things yet and I'm like dude this
guy's got what it takes and I'll tell
them I'm like dude I know you're young
and this is your second deal but like
you're killing it You're Gonna Go Far
like let's keep in touch because I see
in you what I see in these 45 55 60 year
old people are there any people like
that that you can name like say you're
like watch this person uh
just pick one
so who now whoever you don't need is
gonna be mad yeah that's why I was
thinking about it I'm like now there's
gonna be ten of those guys that are like
dude come on you name this guy not me uh
I'll I'll I'll pass on that I'll pass
you told me that there's this book The
New Kings of New York I think is yeah
explain a little bit of what happened in
New York and like why are some of these
people now in uh Miami do they think
they can just kind of run back the
Playbook or uh something else yeah so I
think New York and I can't really speak
to it I wasn't someone that lived there
for a bunch of years and I don't know
all the politics and stuff like that but
it's an older city right especially when
you compare it to Miami
um so the new Kings of New York that
book specifically talks about a lot of
like sort of like the new Titans that
are there now so Steven Ross being one
of them uh second dorf Harry macklow all
these guys that were fighting for and
bidding and winning 500 million two
billion dollar buildings
what I like about that book is that
they're talking about New York and as
I'm seeing and reading about this cast
and crew
they're
if not all in Miami or in South Florida
they're making big plans to come over
here right even maklow had
um an investment in Dadeland that came
out in the newspapers that I think he
either funded or was gonna fund Stephen
Ross has made a huge Splash over here so
what I think is interesting about Miami
where going back to where in the first
inning relative to New York
is Miami's a new city
very very new city and you go back
oh you'd like this it'll be a question
for you you go back a hundred years
right so we're in college 2020 right you
go back to 1920. you go back to 1920 and
there was this guy named Carl Fisher if
you've heard of Fisher Island yep that's
Carl Fisher
he was selling Waterfront Lots in Miami
Beach
an acre on the water in Miami Beach for
guess how much money
foreign
500 for an acre yeah on the water in
Miami Beach right fast forward the
Austin Martin residences side in
downtown Miami that's on the water is
like a 100 million acre for land
Ken Griffin that just bought
um 2.5 acres on a parking lot next to
Jade uh ocean right here it's in
Brickell it's a water to 2.5 acre
Waterfront lot in Brickell 363 million
dollars which is 150 million dollars the
acre fifty dollars he was selling
Waterfront lots for on Miami Beach crazy
Miami Beach is it's it's insane so
what's interesting is
because South Florida is so new it's 100
years old tops
the infrastructure is also very new so
you've got people like uh West Edens a
fortress Investment Group that's funding
the bright line right that's starting
right now
go and try to create a bright Line in
New York right because the Metro is what
old and smelly and dense whatever it may
be it's already there you're not moving
New York you're not replacing I can't
speak to this technically but like
you're not replacing the insist the
existing infrastructure in New York why
is West doing that it's a capitalistic
Pursuit like they're gonna make money on
the bright line it's or is it a
philanthropic
I think a little of both I think when
you get to his level of wealth you're
not you know maximizing profit as in
like the end-all be-all it's like hey I
hope it pencils but like I want to do
this for you know the people in the
country and it could be an ego on
another man personally yeah
um but yeah it's definitely and I think
you could read about it it's like
they're losing money you know day in and
day out and pretty much
so if you look at downtown Miami where
the bright line starts down here they
have a whole mixed-use project around it
right so they've got office towers that
Blackstone now owns
it's a good example Blackstone goes and
leases 40 000 square feet of office
space in downtown Miami
six months later they're buying the
building for 250 million dollars right
so again this is starting to happen
right and then when Blackstone owns and
Brookfield asset management and all
these players so going back to West
Edens
he basically I believe is now selling
like parkline uh aside from the office
buildings that he built there that he
sold
there's apartment towers that ended up
selling recently for like 450 million
dollars so he's creating the nucleus
with the bright line then he's selling
the assets
to then continue funding the bright line
because he wants to create like the
largest
private railroad you know public transit
um uh system in Florida so
I'm sure there's a lot of intentions as
to why he's doing it but he's going to
open the Aventura right now it's it's
you can brightline from Miami to Fort
Lauderdale to West Palm Beach
right
he's opening the Aventura station either
this month in December or January it'll
be fully open and then he's going to
have Orlando he's going to have Tampa so
going back to just like how
how early of a City Florida is in South
Florida specifically it's like we can
see what Chicago Boston New York did
right or did wrong from a urban planning
perspective and like mitigate those
issues
let's break down a deal like let's say
someone wants to buy a 100 million
dollar deal how much money do they have
to put in how much of its debt uh are
there other considerations like what
what goes into a hundred million dollar
uh multi-family purchase yeah so a lot
less than most people think okay explain
for sure so when people say I own a 100
million dollar deal you know that's not
100 million dollars they could sell then
have cash equivalent in their bank
account so
I'll explain to you what's called a
capital stack which is like okay you've
got a 100 million dollar deal how does
that break down right so call it 60 of
that is a loan from A bank right so
someone's lending you 60 of that asset
so-called 60 million dollars comes from
a bank then you've got 40 million
dollars of equity which is the remaining
Capital that you've got to fill up
out of that 40 million dollars let's say
this acquisition was happening by a pump
Capital Partners right You've Got to Now
raise 40 million dollars of equity
typically you raise that you do 90
percent
by limited partners so you go out and
raise 90 of that money and you fund ten
percent of it so out of that 40 million
dollars you're funding personally four
million dollars and you're going to go
raise 36 million dollars right the
interesting thing is that then the
personal pump Capital Partners four
million dollar
tranche
that could be
us here in this room each putting a
million dollars right so it's four guys
that got together four million dollars
within Palm Capital who then raised 36
million dollars who then got from a bank
60 million dollars for this 100 million
dollar building and then typically how
it works is from an investment
standpoint
the 60 million dollar the bank has like
the safest return but no upside the
limited partners that come in for 36
million dollars they've got like the
second safest return and some of the
upside right because they're taking more
risk and then us four in this room
putting a million dollars each have the
most risk but the most upside what is
when you say uh the LPS have some of the
upside what does that look like so
typically in real estate Investments
they'll promise you like a six to eight
percent return
a year in your money so out of that 36
million dollars that could be one person
giving you a 36 million dollar check
which will be a big institutional group
or you can go and find 36
1 million dollar checks right what
you're promising to those people is like
hey if you give me a million dollars I
will return to you six percent preferred
return
and then once we sell the asset or
refinance it and have a capital event
and we get all this money back
once you get your full million dollars
back
and your six percent return or eight
percent return whatever it's negotiated
that's accrued to you then we go and
split the funds instead of 90 10 which
is how you came into the deal 90 LP 10
GP instead of 90 10 then we'll go and
split the funds 80 20. up to a 12 return
then once we've given you a 12 return
every dollar that comes in after a 12
return we're gonna split it 70 30. so
how it looks like when you have an
investment that has a 40 return
right is your million dollar our four
guy million dollar investment goes and
becomes a four five six seven Equity
multiple right it like escalates really
really quickly while the lp sort of like
tapers off a little bit because the more
money we're making them
the high the more upside we're getting
from it the higher percentage the higher
percentage so typically it's a six to
eight percent preferred return that's
like you're getting that yes or yes and
then after that after a 12 return you
get a little bit less of the upside up
through a 20 return you get a little bit
less it's all how you structure it
and most of the individuals who are
running these firms are there other fees
that they're charging uh in terms of uh
it obviously they're going to get their
carry or which the 20 or whatever yeah
uh they're gonna probably get some
management fees uh but on like
individual deals are there fees as well
that they end up taking or like how does
that work yeah so there's like deal
level returns which is like hey that's
what the asset is going to give us and
then there's like net to investors so
your typical fees is the acquisition fee
an asset management fee
a property management fee
and then sometimes a disposition fee so
those are your typical fees I want to
say largely because I know you're going
to ask like what do those fees look like
and where should they be at yeah
um so largely call it an acquisition fee
will be one to two percent it obviously
varies if you're buying a billion dollar
asset right versus a five million dollar
asset but typically an acquisition fee
which you pay to the sponsor for closing
on that asset is one to two percent why
are you paying them that one to two
percent because yes they're closing on
this asset mostly with your money but to
close on this asset they went and
underwrote and looked at 150 properties
of course with people that they were
paying 150 000 a year in salary to fly
out to Florida and fly out to Fort
Lauderdale and fly out this
so a one to two percent acquisition
acquisition fee typically also like a
one to two percent asset management fee
which this is like doing k1s and a bunch
of back end things that gets paid
you do a three to five percent
management fee right three percent for
these larger 300 unit buildings
five percent to these smaller 50 unit
buildings right because it's more
nominal so it's nominally less dollars
and then you've got disposition fees hey
we're selling this thing now we get
that's like 50 basis points if they even
add it so typically what you see doing
it what you see sponsors doing is if
it's their first deal
there be the most lenient with fees
because what they want to build is a
track record so I'm invested in a deal
um with a partner where they're like hey
this is our first deal I knew them from
a while back because they used to be ex
Blackstone type guys so I'm like these
guys are very sharp very smart but
they're sort of being lenient on fees
because they need to build a track
record so they were doing like a one
percent acquisition fee
it was a one percent asset management
fee
three percent management fee and no
disposition fee so I'm like okay these
guys are as sharp as a Blackstone guys
and they're basically charging me no
fees right and they're just on the
upside of the opportunity itself great
as that group's grown I think they
bought over a billion dollars worth of
real estate last year as that group's
grown and more and more people want to
give them money they start having more
leverage to be like hey Omar
we're raising money again in case you
want to come in on this deal but now
it's a two percent acquisition fee two
percent disposition like and they'll go
and do more market rate expenses because
now they have the leverage they have
people that want to give them money yeah
it's all uh Supply demand
all supply and demand how should people
think about uh they get pitched all the
time whether it's technology products
whether it's individual uh GPS on the
internet whether it's somebody that they
got introduced to by their friend or
whatever uh that's raising money for a
real estate deal like how do you
underwrite who uh you would give your
money to or who you would like what are
things that uh you look for what are red
flags what are things that yeah they're
like okay this this is a signal that
this person knows what they're talking
about it's definitely Case by case but I
think
my number one thing is track record it's
like let me see how many deals you've
purchased and how those deals did
and then also you want to see how much
experience do they have in that sub
market right generally speaking you want
to do business if you want to get
exposure to multi-family Assets in South
Florida you want to do it with the team
that's done 5 10 15 deals here
successfully you're probably less
inclined to do it with the team that's
like very successful in Michigan but is
now doing their first the first South
Florida deal we had a client once where
that was sort of the what happened they
were out of Towners and they were doing
a deal on Coral Gables and they put one
of their leasing agents I couldn't speak
Spanish because they're from Michigan
and they don't know this and they were
like dude like the buildings around us
are killing it and ours isn't doing so
hot and I didn't find out for them but I
found out this was the issue their whole
staff didn't speak a lick of Spanish if
you've been in Miami you got to speak
some Spanish Spanish is actually the
language of South Florida English is a
nice to have actually though yeah I'm
not joking yeah yeah you order your food
in Spanish yeah it's interesting some
people like it and the people that don't
you can go to Fort Lauderdale yeah or
Palm Beach we've got it all in South
Florida so
um that's that's one one example of
something to look at which is like okay
what's your track record look like in a
specific sell Market
another thing is fees I just spoke about
them obviously if they're charging you
crazy outrageous fees it's like wait no
yeah
um that's another thing but
realistically you want to have someone
generally like pomp if you're investing
in multi-family in South Florida yeah
you get a confidential private placement
memorandum sent to you it's kind of like
hey nudge nudge wink wink Omar have you
ever heard of these guys and I get that
question all the time and I've sold a
lot of multi-family in South Florida
when my friend sent me these Investments
and I'm like I have never [ __ ] heard
of this person in my life and they don't
have a website and I've never seen like
that's when you're like red flags are
popping out once you're dealing with
like
I think Venture is very similar right
where it's like yeah stripe great
company um
hey Omar I wanna like Palm can you get I
got 50 Grand can you put it in stripe
for me you're like yeah good [ __ ]
luck like you need series I don't know
whatever and you have access that's
where it gets very interesting being a
broker
where I have access to the best GPS the
best sponsors who are always over
allocated on their Investments if they
need to raise 10 million dollars they're
going to find it because for the last 15
years 40 years they've made money for
their investors so what I
do is tell these groups like hey can you
carve out some money for me or can you
carve out some money for my friend
the reason they do that is because we're
the ones that sell the deals to them
right so when I'm selling a deal to XYZ
firm
we could have sold that deal to the
other guy that maybe had the same offer
with the same deposits and the same
terms but we really told the seller like
hey this guy is like
he's never done us any wrong he's a
great guy that guy yeah it's the same
terms on paper but like we don't really
know him we've never dealt with them
right so the sponsors also want the
Brokers that are sort of controlling
these deals in in some respect right at
the end of the day the seller has a
final say
once the broker's on their side and when
I get a deal that's like under the table
like hey I don't want you to Market this
but I need you to close this deal for
this price I call my top five guys my
top 10 guys those top five guys those
top 10 guys give me like private access
to their Investments and for me
personally like Omar funds go to those
guys which are like over allocated tried
and true charge market rate fees and
have a huge track record yeah that makes
a lot of sense what are like the biggest
risks that people should pay attention
to risks
um like there's like outright fraud and
that type of stuff correct yeah I was
gonna say but like that's hard to sort
of gauge a track record is a good way to
gauge for that um and the actual
investment yeah like if you're doing a
multi-family investment what are like
the two or three things you're like okay
these are the risks that I always check
for yeah pretty quickly so if somebody
sends you a package which says hey you
shouldn't invest with us look at this
investment that we have under contract
that we're going to close on the number
one thing you should probably look for
and this is a good red flag and any real
estate guy will tell you this but people
that are you know a lawyer or a doctor
won't know this is look at the cap rate
right which is like the yield that
you're going into on this asset look at
the cap rate call it it's a five percent
cap rate that you're going into this
investment look at their projections
going forward and look if they projected
that they're going to sell it
for a lower cap rate which is more
expensive for a lower cap rate than
they're buying it at right so if I tell
you I am buying this out of five cap and
in five years I'm going to sell it out
of four cap
what makes it a five cap and a four cap
is the market is your own power right
now it's the FED right so you want to
bet on somebody that the operations of
the asset is what's paying your money
not
what the 10-year treasury is going to be
four or five years from now so you want
to make sure that the exit cap
is higher than the going in cap
so that's like a specific example and
like that's like generalized would be
like you can make money whether the
Market's up or down they're going to do
things with this property that will
improve its value right and so therefore
even if you're in a worse economic
environment it's still a good deal yeah
I mean there's deals right now that I
invested in that were purchased out of
four cap and now the Market's closer to
a five cap so like the asset value has
gone down on paper but the two thousand
dollar rents that they're gonna renovate
the units so then charge three thousand
dollars they're renovating those units
and they're getting three thousand
dollars whether the paper value of the
building is up or down so my eight
percent
is getting paid quarterly right and
that's what I care about I can't control
what the ex what the cap rate is going
to be right it's like if I tell you hey
the p e ratio of the stock is five p e
ratio and when we're going to sell is
going to be 20p ratio I'm like all right
well are you changing it from a
industrial stock to a tech stock like
how are you doing that [ __ ] yeah you're
not
yeah and then when you think about a
young person who wants to get into real
estate like what's your best advice for
them
I do this a lot because on Twitter and
stuff like that
I think you definitely want to
real estate is competitive
Barry Stern Lake I don't know if it was
Barry Stone like the Starwood capital or
David Rubinstein of Carlisle group but
one of them too had like a commencement
address for speech and they basically
said like
I look at where all the Harvard
graduates and Wharton graduates that
could have their pick of their litter of
where they want to go to the mbas and
like that industry that everybody wants
to go to is the one that I think is
overvalued and like due for a crash
because that's what all the smart cool
kids want to do now
and the reason I mentioned that is
because real estate is like a
competitive tough
group like industry to really make good
like you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars for the average Focus great
money
um so it's gonna be competitive what's
interesting about that is
to break in is going to be hard right
unless you come from a great school and
you've got the background connection and
all that stuff to break in it's going to
be hard but if you figure out a way to
break in my I got into real estate in a
very atypical way I was a b student with
no internships and I fell into this
thing
but I called hundreds of people that I
read on the real deal the south Florida
Business Journal and I'm like Mitch
simberg who runs our entire Florida team
is someone I called in 2015 for advice
and then fast forward seven years and
he's like the guy that runs the team
that I'm working with
um so advice that I would give to a
younger person is like
get book recommendations that get you
into real estate that will talk about
real estate and read these books or look
at videos on YouTube about real estate
and how these people are making money
and if you're doing that
and it's not peaking your interest or
your curiosity quite frankly like pivot
and go go do something else go do
something else because it's so
competitive in here I tell people I'm
like dude if you're failing to break in
even if you manage to break in you're
gonna have a really tough time making a
lot of money in this industry because
there's a lot of people that
found figured out a way to break it and
those are the people you're gonna now be
competing with
right so I think it's self-selecting
that way but advice would be that for me
when I was not in real estate I reached
out
legit first job in real estate company
called Lloyd Jones capital I reached out
to the CEO founder of the company
ignored me obviously reached out to the
CFO ignored me obviously reached out to
the director of Acquisitions ignored me
obviously reached out to every VP
analyst I could find nobody replied
nobody nobody The Intern
Riley the intern reached back out to me
like hey bro yeah I would love to grab
lunch
go grab lunch with this guy I come with
like my manila folder and resume seven
eight years ago in case the conversation
goes well conversation goes well I give
them my resume he gives it to the guy
they're calling me in for an interview
like a month later and I'm like okay
this is great I get in there they
weren't even looking for someone they
legit we're like we're not hiring but we
think you're great like we like your
energy
as I was walking out of that room
true story as I was walking out of that
room I look at the Bullpen where the
analysts were and there was an empty
desk with two computer screens that were
black and I'm like who sits there
and the founder CEO Chris Finley is like
nobody is empty and I was like
I could I could sit there and just help
you guys out doing whatever whatever it
is you're doing I'll help and he's like
seriously he said well we're not looking
for anyone like we're not we can't pay
you and I was like don't pay me for the
first three months at the time I was
living with my parents which is
fortunate and all these things but I was
like you don't have to pay me a dollar
I'll go over there and just sit and
learn and then three months from my
quote-unquote start date we'll talk
about paying me something if you think
it's worthy if not I'll do what I'm
doing now and just go look around and
try to find a job
I loved it it was like great like when
do you start and I'm like I'll be there
Monday it was like a Thursday or
something like that Monday I show up and
I'm there at the office
I was in at five six in the morning I
was out of there at eight o'clock at
night I wasn't getting paid a dollar but
it put the fire under my ass which is
like the only way I'm going to stay here
is if I prove that I can be very
valuable to this company I spent nights
reading loan documents and JV agreements
and stuff like that that we all had
access to it or just learned the
business
and yeah you you know the rest is
history three months later the guy's
giving me a full-time offer I'm learning
the the business there I'm cutting my
teeth and then here I am you know does
he invest in deals now that you would do
you should go back well that's a great
point so now I see him so now my team we
haven't sold deals to him but my team
has financed deals that he's got in like
Fort Myers and stuff like that yeah and
when I run into him he's like Omar like
how's everything going bro a guy loves
me right and he sees my success and he's
just like dude I knew you were like yeah
you were a badass you were a shark you
know and I'm just like thanks I
appreciate it like you really helped me
out so like if you're not doing by the
way we have this deal do you want to buy
it by the way that's that's my whole
story I'm like are you are you in the
market for something yeah yeah 100 I
love it where can we send people to find
more about the team like brocadia itself
is like a pretty big uh company National
company yeah but how did they find the
south Florida team
um South Florida team honestly I I'm
happy to be like the source right um
which you can find me on Twitter or
Instagram text email whatever it is
where do most people go through Twitter
I think Twitter is where I've started
what's your Twitter so it's at Omar
Morales
m-o-r-a-l-e-s yeah do people hit you up
on Instagram on Instagram dude a lot
because you know what you know why
really because I swear and more more I
don't want to say like real players or
whatever but like
yeah basically I I will post pictures
because the thing is that real estate is
very visual industry right so like
Twitter is really good for like Tech and
crypto and all these things software
engineers and it's great for Real Estate
there's a bunch of big fish on Twitter
but on Instagram
what I've noticed helps me the most is
like if we follow each other like a 55
year old founder of a company and I him
and I follow each other now I am looking
at like the fact that he likes tennis
and the fact that this and the fact that
that so it like grows a relationship and
then I slide into the DMS but instead of
like back in my single days being like a
girl or whatever I'm like sliding into
the DM of some like sponsor and I'm like
yo let's play tennis let's hang out and
it sort of like humanizes the
relationship and I've now done deals
with people that I've met on Instagram
literally they're like oh yeah I see
that you're doing a bunch of stuff and
we meet for coffee and then you know we
go and close the deal on Twitter
actually there was a guy that dm'd me on
Twitter that like six seven months later
I was selling a 110 million dollar deal
too on Twitter he DM me and I reached
out to my team and I'm like this guy
looks pretty real pretty legit so this I
can shout him out as Max sharkanski from
try on properties his last name is
literally shark Kansky
is a Max will legit text me at four in
the morning and then we'll be texting at
11 o'clock at night about a deal he'll
reply at four in the morning and I'm
just like Max bro go to bed but like
these are the type of guys that I'm like
dude this guy is next level if Max is
like yo you want to invest in my deal
I'm like please I'm like take my money
you know it's crazy the max is a Max is
a shark sharkanski yeah he's the best
that's an amazing name that's a dog yeah
no and I introduced him to this other
guy now the CIO of true America his name
is Matt Ferrari so I was like all right
I gotta introduce a shark to this
Ferrari and it was a great conversation
the guys are both stunts it's people
that you sit in the room with I'm sure
you've been in the situation where
you're just like holy [ __ ] like these
people are [ __ ] smart yeah like it's
just every room yeah that's the that's
the only room you want to be in yeah I'm
dumb that's fine that's me here I'm like
I'm hanging out here I'm like all right
this is pretty cool I just saw real
estate awesome all right well listen
thank you so much for coming and doing
this I think this is super helpful for a
lot of people who are interested in real
estate or trying to understand how deals
work uh how the broker versus principle
and kind of that trade-off uh and then
also like why South Florida uh so anyone
who wants to reach out to Omar Omar
Morales on Twitter and uh maybe slide
into his DMS on Instagram as well no
whatever you want to and we'll
definitely do is again in the future
perfect I appreciate you having me here
Bob